okay well for those joining us on the
live stream this is internal design
review meeting about machine learning
functionality and we are looking at a
tiens
screen here so I think this is a
collection of things we're very close to
a release of a new version of often
language so this is kind of taking care
of some details associated with the
machine learning framework this that's
what I hope it this is about yes yes
exactly so it's a bit of a medley of
different things so I don't know in
which order we should go
soldering we should see on your screen
and other things that I should do it's
like okay let's launch anything I should
probably do that Oh My yes these on your
screen these I'm not sure it's committed
so it might differ a few questions for
you but maybe much time this is an your
sister I mean it's kind of you know you
know it's documentation of the of the of
the building classifiers so it's not
like a big document page so I don't
think it requires all your attention but
there was two things we wanted to ask
all right why don't we start off why
don't we go down your agenda in order
why didn't she let me share and let's do
the fun texture on sand I think first
okay is there other nothing that we have
to do as well okay
for those on the
dream who wonder what on earth the term
knitting means it has to do with
providing appropriate cross links in our
documentation by the way do I need to
update my update like what's that oh I
don't know if you change anything the
last hour no nope okay documentation is
not to date in the last build
yes it's up to date you okay all right
so let's sum
okay so we've gone over this
documentation but have we looked at
let's see we did or did not look at the
skills I don't think we did okay those
seemed fairly reasonable let me think
anything else that should be there
mm-hmm no it seems fairly low let's see
what's down here I mean it could relate
to other machine learning functions that
is totally bizarre that the things
referred to from from the wolf now for
function are things like import an XML
element that just seems nuts and I don't
even know how that link that last thing
is made but those don't just seem not
very sensible do you see the reason for
those I mean it seems like odds yeah I
mean interpreter might be a useful thing
like something that you know grammar
rules would probably be useful certainly
we should I would think thankful answer
obviously yeah Wikipedia data is
probably reasonable actually entity
value is surely the most the most
obvious thing
probably enter devalue an interpreter
are two really obvious things fine
textual answer right okay so fine text
or answer also definitely wants to point
to entity value
you
arguably before Wikipedia search hmm
maybe after I don't know maybe after
okay let's go look at those pages so
let's say text cases
I reckon it belongs at the end here to
agree yes yes yeah text search
fine also
I think
I think really depends on how good it is
well I think if it was fantastic
then it deserves to be slightly earlier
in some of these lists and one day and
gradually it will become more fantastic
hopefully of course um okay text search
Wikipedia search I on earth does this
not refer to text search
and
[Music]
devalue what on earth does that refer to
interesting
okay all right where are we knitting
this let's go um let's see I just look
at Wikipedia I'm not sure that actually
that's the first thing to look at let's
look at text cases probably where is
that appear processing textual data text
analysis sort of there
you
you
you think it belongs in here
it's parsing
that's kind of where it belongs right it
looks reasonable in yeah I think so too
attempt to find
what do we gonna call it
Mantic how do we describe the semantic
answers what are we what are we
describing it as attempt to find answers
to questions in text from text
I'd seem reasonable yep okay
now we want to go also that was okay
let's look at machine learning so this
is this with uh this um I'm identify and
stuff like that
yeah machine learning applications it's
down here right yeah
natural language processing applications
why does their dock which doesn't go
anywhere
down underneath Eris's at single-line
also probably use the very same line
you
this is machine learning so we can
say find answers to questions from text
rather than attempt to find since
everything is an attempt
okay all right let's
okay let's look at four
and see Wikipedia data
knowledge
additional access
and linguistic data we might consider
also okay knowledge representation and
access
what no it was definitely not okay that
formatting was removed there that's
completely crazy
and that's wrong - um is anybody is
anybody any p.m. in this beating
nope okay with you
well this is definitely wrong so so can
we get some could somebody send mail to
Brian and ask him to fix these
yes shall I do it
I'll do it
it's the first
I can fix those myself Oh interesting
you
you
that's just crazy okay let me just take
that page and ask Brian to fix it
hold on
you
you
okay all right let's look at this page
I'll come on this page is all messed up
what now happened here I really don't
think I'm the one to fix these I don't
know why dqa didn't just fix the stuff
which is crazy what the heck's going on
you
you
what is this
w a bitmaps what on earth is this
um can somebody try and find bryan
pemberton
you
as Eric here okay all right
you
okay um let's have a separate section
here since this is about knowledge
representation access textual question
answering
you
you
okay
okay anything else for this one so
that's the Knitting of fine texture
answer any other places that we need to
knit it do you think oh you know what
web search it should connect to web
search
[Music]
well at least it should refer to web
search I think
you
in fact before Wikipedia search it
should refer to web search
well the mother was trained on Wikipedia
so it should work better with Wikipedia
pages them so I understand that but I'm
saying if you are looking for this
function what else might you want okay
whatever let's do that okay okay
anything else for fine textual answer it
okay look quickly at the documentation
page of so since I'm not sure it's
committed is it committed I mean you
just show you screen and just show one
yep okay this page this knowledge
representation access page is full of
garbage look at all these boxes no no
it's not oh that was from 11:15 that was
from two weeks ago
oh yeah yeah could you could you make
sure these get taken care of some of
these look really weird that W a bitmaps
thing looks really weird yes that is
weird okay yeah I'll take care of it
okay would you like me let's see how
much more stuff do we have that involves
me editing documentation a 10 you
nothing okay fine I will push the
documentation back right now
um okay thanks done burn yeah well I'll
get the message to and I'll I'll take
care of it once it's done okay thanks a
lot Bren can stay just community small
it's a very quick question amia will
show you know I may will show you screen
and maybe the I may go ahead and show
yes sure so there are about fourteen a
new documentation page for building
classifiers I'm gonna just show you two
which is a new format these pages is
that new ml models for machine learning
models both link pacifiers this is a new
format yes so first thing we need to
look at is just a general thing is it
okay right what are these what do these
look like when they're built nothing yet
that's on my to-do list to get them what
it where's the template that these are
are these from the other button in the
ducky tools there's right now you can't
get to it from dr. tools that was
something that I built just for these
guys there's a language level way to
access this tough foot okay what is it
guys you have it in front of you I would
have to look it up okay but so we tweet
so there are pages like this for every
built-in classifier is that correct yes
it is correct about 14 of them yes I
just wanted to you to see and just
review the overall no I understand but
we also need graphic design for the for
the actual way that these pages get
built and Brian who is who is taking
care of that it's would be Heidi I we
have to double check there's the ticket
could you make sure that there is of
course okay
yeah the design would be I don't know I
mean we could do the same as for the
machine learning methods or I mean I
think there what machine leads first of
all each machine learning method as wait
a minute what isn't built the pages look
like I mean for example the format pages
are an example of a filter page yeah
when you go to one go ahead yeah can you
show maybe yes sure
like this one yeah I think it will show
like this yeah it like that new these
are new oh yeah - I think yeah
whereas the is there a guide page that
has that links to all of these it's in
classifying predicts all the methods in
the other link can I can I see that yeah
yeah so if I just click on yeah Natalie
you're gonna date an uptrend and where
you have the list of things yeah like
building classifiers here and go down
for the method
you know that is options method six I
know the guy that saw these click on
support vector machine just as a random
example oh well the last one yeah
hold on hold on for a second
interesting could you could you open
details and sub-options why are we not
doing a thumbnailing thing there it's I
mean it's on the list of a fun nailing
for all the rest of the pages as well
it's the hope is that we're gonna get
some built-in tuning from John's group
rather than having to construct it I
mean this thing that you have there the
kernel bla bla bla takes the form would
be better as a table wouldn't it
probably yes definitely okay yeah
keep scrolling down there's some
[Music]
keeps going keeps climbing we should do
so what happens on the classified page
itself when you talk about methods do
you point over to these pages or what so
in the decision sorry
in the deterrent option yes yes Dilys
now we have to put more links in the
examples you know like the method
examples we don't have much links yet we
should put you know can we talk about a
method put the link okay so your plan
right now in terms of built-in
classifiers so I I believe these
built-in classifiers should also go on
some proper top level guide page in
addition to going inside the classify
documentation get scroll up to the top
of the classify documentation okay
actually I don't mean the top I mean I
mean the place yeah right right now
you're gonna list every single one of
those built-in classifier functions that
we have there then those things will
become links yep right but what I'm
saying is I think we need a separate
page for built-in we might put these
even on the machine learning um on the
machine learning once we have these
links Brian I mean it's another little
piece of knitting that we have to go
back to the machine learning guide page
and probably put these on there
I think the machine learning guide page
is becoming too long and I suspect we're
going to need to break some pieces off
yeah maybe so yeah all right but in
terms of what you're doing here so every
one of these will get something so let's
take a look then facial expression yes
is built in seven classes can be
returned oh that's one
so sometimes it's a few classes actually
I believe that for seven classes it
should be in the text but not as a list
yeah I don't know I mean it come due I'd
like to see I feel I feel I feel more
like that with a dot but now there's a
question what what do we do when we are
fifteen yeah for example like this one
we have notable persons we have a lot of
them so we were thinking to put like few
of them and then dot a dot and then the
last one with that well vine more like
an entity page so gosh there's a whole
different design Brian said you knows
what it is for entity page entity type
pages yeah like look at the city energy
by the way I'm here we should put the
number of class in that case should put
one file in the class you know one for
this can be returned
mm-hmm it's useful good information of
the number and then you have a sample I
think yeah hold on
I mean I'm not so excited about is there
not some programmatic way that you can
see what classes there are information
yes definitely so why don't we just show
that as an example somewhere rather than
just say I don't think showing the case
of facial expression it's useful to see
what's returned yeah exactly I mean you
you came up you came to this classifier
and yes what is that and for example of
classes you're filling yeah by the way
that redness of the of that option there
okay no matter that that's fine
yes it won't be like this okay great
okay yes
top probability and then we can have
like classifier information also okay
hold on let's go back up to the top of
this one yes sure
[Music]
yeah I think you
just say in the and the notable people I
think you should say about a thousand
can be returned and not and not going to
details there and in the examples you
can show you know in the properties and
relations section which I hope you have
do you have a properties in relation
section no there's only two thousand
options no I mean I mean examples
example no we just add one type of
examples I don't write idea I think you
should do the same type of thing that we
do but other functions I think those
categories work well so you know basic
examples scope just one classifier you
know you know this classifier when you
show it once or twice then you know how
to use it you know oh I agree but if you
had a section you don't have to fill out
every section but if you have another
section called properties and relations
and all it has in it look at how to get
the complete list that's right I mean so
in other words you spec these pages to
have basic examples because I can
imagine that application examples are
going to be relevant for some of these
classifiers notable people there's not
particularly you know important but you
know for facial expression I can imagine
that there's something where there's an
application example that combines facial
expressions with find faces and things
like this and they're making sense
yes um
now I don't understand why related
examples do you really want to put every
you're basically putting every single
model into related models there is that
really relevant I mean do you think
that's relevant and there's not that
many yeah but I don't think language
it's not a relevant - Godzilla the goal
is to put ones that are relevant okay so
on little remnants of facial expression
sentiment is relevant okay no you know
just no no no doubt down in related
models related models if you could yes
Facebook topic just not relevant I mean
I tell me why it's relevant it's these
are all the built-in classifiers and
[Music]
element facial age is obviously relevant
look sentiment is relevant facial age
facial gender Facebook yes okay except W
you might as well leave its sort of
relevant I suppose I can't imagine what
they hard to imagine that one for a
patient okay you'll deal with it yes sir
okay okay I think that was it for well
hold on hold on hold on hold on so
you've done this for every one of these
yes right yes that is correct
can i 14 off those yes yeah can I see
another random one like sentiment for
example yes sure
yeah here we put it in line positive
neutral or negative yes but those should
be those should be um made to be literal
input just to stay yes yes yes yeah the
whole thing needs to be Stern yeah
since the sentiment the built-in quest
for itself users naivebayes but women
now you place is a function cook it
click it I think it's a mistake it's a
muscle learning method so then then it
referred to that way it's being referred
to it makes it look like it's a function
so if you're gonna do that and I
wouldn't really go into that the
question of what method it uses because
I think that's a you know may change and
who knows mm-hmm yeah I think we should
put it yes sure
sorry I didn't have a full thorough
review yet we're just you know you okay
fine just Brian looked at those are
questions I have not looked at the
content yet no yeah okay fine um all
right let's let's um but these look nice
yeah I mean is there any other one that
has a very different type of thing in it
here
no actually this is just their image
ones are pretty similar to the one that
you saw for example just like quickly
this one also like NSFW it's very
similar to the other ones returned not
safe or safe just leave out the not safe
ones for the yeah okay you've just got
problems yes um so they're very similar
there are two types with the image as
similar and if like things like it's
very nice okay can you unsure your
screen yes sure don't forget to push
those changes back and so on
okay is this everything for Brian but
let's see let's see what's next
am I going to my screen are we going to
adhere in screen I sent I send you
actually the day if you want okay but
yeah we're done with documentation okay
nothing Brian can go and probably Jerome
can go as well how we just find you
actually let's just find the agenda for
a second yeah okay so now we talk
classified pretty taxing okay fine
yep so goodbye to Brian goodbye to
Jerome I think I want to stay but it's a
bit late so um all right all right so
these are our new things
let's see where we have okay the most
important thing that I wanted to talk
about what about this direct training I
think that the main design decision we
need to take and the other one more
small thing so boy okay yeah so this is
the day before the freeze of dispersion
well I try to talk about that a few
times and yeah doesn't been successful
but that's okay it's just one little
change huh okay okay all right okay what
are we looking at here so the question
so I didn't put anything in
documentation because so we need to
figure out okay some future ice thing so
we need an option to prevent classify
and predict to start the big expensive
automation procedure and just you just
train a role model and run them
basically and random or or based on you
can add heuristics before we started the
multi yeah but that's not okay this the
point of this option is really for the
user to how you say shortcuts to tap
directly into our pure implementation so
it will be used by people when they when
I specify the method when they specify
the upper parameter for example and if
there's something leaner specified in
that case it's at random but it will be
used I think by users when they we
specify everything
he's also a poet scholar automatic will
be overwritten by a specific method
right
I mean method goes to automatic yes
what we're looking at here is the
performance goal right so oh okay
these were just one design at some point
I thought we I thought that maybe we
could put on performance work but I'm
not I don't think that's okay explain
the scenario so the the main thing that
happens right now is we set up you know
all the automation starts running we're
trying multiple methods in parallel lots
of clever things that happen right this
is the case where somebody just says I
want to use naivebayes I don't care
about anything else is that right
not exactly so the user can already
specify methods that can also specifies
suburb friends for the given method okay
it will still plot a learning curve for
example it will still so my example is a
bit bad here because I just have a data
set of size 4 but let's say let's say
chemists you can put a mist which was a
type if you want okay should I just do
it yeah although I'm not showing the
version you have is everything is fine
but you know that's a production that's
the head branch build should I get to
prototype no no no I mean try there may
be some message because yeah ok so on in
these it will try by training things
with let's say 50 example then 500
example then 2,000 examples and it will
you know plot this learning curve even
if you specify entirely the method and
and some option you want to use it will
still do this learning curve because
it's a valuable thing for the user to
have this learning curve so what this
often we do is not do a learning curve
just trained on the food that I said
don't do any testing and in the case
that you didn't specify everything it
will pick whatever it doesn't know at
random like all other parameter it
doesn't know at random
yeah well so that seems to me you know
with our current setup that fits best
and performance go it's yeah yeah I mean
actually in a sense it would fit more
with method but the problem is that you
could specify method and specify this
thing as well performance goal you could
also have some overlap you could say do
a direct training with a performance
goal quality look one possibility would
be I'm not sure it's beautiful but one
possibility would be something like this
where you have direct training and then
direct training arrow and then other
method stuff no well I mean it would
it's saying this is a meta method right
yes exactly that's why at some point I
thought maybe automation search method
or automation method and many methods in
many functions are there method of
automation
no it's for many functions method itself
is specifying method of automation
let's see so one thing that I thought
the actual you can see it here was
either you put method direct training
find this kind of a shortcut to do it or
if you specify method you put direct
training goes to true or random training
goes to true maybe I don't know how it
should call it well but okay well fine
well we can address the question but I
mean this seems to me to be a somewhat I
mean it's a little weird but that's
that's making the point that there's a
sort of aim yeah I'm not sure that like
this um you could also just be
automation true/false for one under the
method option no it will be like a new I
don't believe in it I don't believe
you're switch off automation it's like
no because there's tons of other
automation you're not switching off I
mean it's true that's true
that's what okay that's why at some
point I could it's automation search I
understand this look this is a fairly
specific thing what you're doing is
you're saying that logistic regression
normally with method logistic regression
you
I don't know
I have to say I think that it fits in
performance goal because okay can you
give another performance goal or does
this Trump all other performance goals
actually no you're right
you can give a list of performance ago
so we support that so we could say in
sports we'll put direct rain I think so
it's direct training the right term um
probably not okay but let's let's think
about what the right term is so this
thing is
it's not a terrible term
for what this is
you
okay let's say train
you
only once on the full dataset without
um avoid adaptivity basically avoid
model search without without model
search all data set without model
searching
you
I'll be fine with that
on performers go simple does introduce
any new symbol fine let's do it
why is my thing set oh I see because I'm
using okay okay and and then before it
was some only let's go with the feature
extractor okay that's something that you
you really think we should do it this
way is this is this gonna involve more
documentation on my part again no I will
do it I will do it I mean this we need
to address the condition but I think I
can do it
there's no no need for you to do it I
just can push that change okay so this
is kind of a just confirmation that's
what I want to do you know so so idea is
you extract features first then you try
to classify all these extracted features
and then you think oh actually I should
include my feature extractor in the
classifier and you do that by reapplying
classify on the classifier and you set
the option feature extractor - my head
is spinning slightly on this okay
explain this to me again so it's it's
very classic actually it's very classic
framework that's a workflow that's why
we put it is you have some data you
first you do some processing on a date
time so let me just to read through what
you have here so you have a feature
extraction it gives you a feature
extractor function there are the
features exactly now a train a
classifier using these extracted
features okay which which now for some
reason your retyping in what the
original values were no that's why I put
something different I mean I mean can
you predict or it can be anything right
yes
sorry it's confusing that I put you've
got a classifier function and then the
question that the real meat is in the
last line where you where classifier is
applied to
classifier function exactly okay let me
think about that for a second so what
that means is so normally that first
argument to classify would be a bunch of
training examples
right
exactly sorry always mute yeah okay so
what you've done is instead of the
training examples you've packaged it in
this classifier function I mean in other
words the classifier function is
standing in for training examples it's a
pre trained class per classifier yeah I
mean this seems quite sensible to me I
mean so a no op you just say classify of
C it will be a no op yes yes actually I
also set up so you can change the
internal like if you want change the
utility function or the class priors or
fine I think that idea but I mean so
then then just in terms of what it
actually has to say right so we need to
say in the in the documentation for
classify but we need to say yeah I
didn't add the line I think I would put
that I don't know at the end of the day
an option or something
oh you you didn't write in the usage
line
I'm thinking I mean it goes along with
this right I mean I would think this
would go in I would think it would be
something like classify
you
how could it last now we classify
function and Kumar hammock wait wait
wait wait wait here we've got
you
Thank You Lana boy you're right you're
right it should go lost
you
you
so this would be something like classify
of a classifier
and then commanding there were some
options yeah tomahawks um in these takes
an existing classifier
yeah an override or other way you should
also make it work to say classify
accommodator which should be equivalent
to just classify off data okay yeah yeah
takes an existing classifier function
and REE
saya and and revises it no that's a bad
word and and updates it with new options
and retrains and don't retrain Alexandre
train okay updates modern - um with the
new options given
okay yeah then I'll show some example
right and you might want to say okay and
does predict do the same thing predict
do the same thing yet and actually what
else dimension reduce yeah you might or
addiction the same thing as well alright
so figure out I'll do that yep yep
things on all of those okay and then I
think the main thing and there is some
little stuff if you go a bit above oh
yeah that's some simple chain that I did
like in classified information now I did
use a evaluation time of an example so
that's just another property in
classifier yes exactly but it's
interesting because it computes it when
you call for class for information it
actually runs one example to see how
long it takes on your machine yeah hold
on
and I think I did it call evaluation
time
is that really right to have non string
cases here that seems kind of weird I
think that's not the right thing I mean
you might as a courtesy accept those but
I would add in string of five versions
of those things
don't decision a long time for good I
don't make sense I don't think that
makes sense I think that if um I really
don't think it makes sense I think you
should document the string of five
version but except the symbol as a
courtesy
okay
okay so what you're saying is you're
adding
raishin time which you didn't tag
properly as 11.3 that's right oh because
it was there before I think okay no no
no no you're right I didn't take it well
yeah okay so and you're suggesting batch
evaluation time is another thing or
batch elaboration time is an alternate
name for evaluation time no butter
finishing time is another thing that I
might have two guys for information
already I didn't test fire measurements
and know the only thing I want to talk
about actually this was more sorry
details what is reports so I did a
report so if you do a classifier
measurements if you see at the end of
the bottom of you notebook your letters
failure yeah you have the cash flow
measurements and then I have a report
thing that kind of give a report which i
think is very useful so we want
something like that to I did Casa fire
measurements not what is this thing
that's returning why is it not so just
returning something okay it's returning
an object that you can query right
because then it's much faster you did a
job only once to evaluate the model and
then you can query values properties
it's very fast
there is a test set but these are things
that you can do even without a test set
or not know okay that but there's a test
set classifier measurements right it's a
test set don't object I think that is
incredibly ugly at that size scale to a
different size I mean I think you unless
you prevent it doing it well there are
heuristics for auto scaling things like
that um yeah we should make it smaller I
want to weigh two things right I mean
they're heuristics that are used for the
for image um I wonder Brett would
probably have opinions about it because
that's an is that a matrix plot yes okay
so I would recommend I would recommend
following something like the heuristics
used for image but Brett would probably
have opinions and if you need to
somebody like Giulio would know what the
heuristics are for images yep um okay so
that's what is this now other than the
fact that that's ugly so it's it's a
reporter reports of the main things
including the second single evaluation
time and the batch evaluation speed yeah
I think it's nicer this way all day was
uniform I mean these these networks yeah
I guess in the current world these
things are always uniform they may not
always be that way
what a mean uniform well there's no
conditionals in the evaluation time the
evaluation time is always the same
oh yeah in this generally it is yes for
NLP and like some model networks it will
be quite different depending on the
input but in that case is quite uniform
and anyway I just wanna show you that
because I was thinking maybe classifier
measurements objects itself should be
something like that
well yes that would be what I would have
thought I'm a parent but pretends more
useful that way
I mean are you computing all that stuff
anyway
it's very fast yeah there's no problem
of of timing there then I agree with you
I think that's what classify
measurements objects should display us
just like system information displays as
a thing like that but can then be sub
you know you can then look at pieces of
it that make sense
now we have to figure out it with the
graphic design yes I mean I don't think
this is urgent for tomorrow no um but I
agree I think that's the right direction
to go in I mean let's look at how system
information does its thing
yeah I'm pretty sure you can then take
system information the object that comes
out and do sub do I doesn't seem to say
it here but um
yeah that you can take that we should
look at this but you can take that and
then take a specific sub property there
like sense I mean I think if I say I
need to get going in a second here um
you
you
that of links
you
weird in that case you mean it would
also remove the
measurement objects head that is
surrounding the report well I'm yeah the
sub value like that but this sub value
should work I don't know why it doesn't
um
yeah that that one should work okay I
think this is a separate discussion it
will be a good LCC discussion to deal
with this for a bunch of different cases
of these graphical objects and then
getting some values of them yeah I
should run off to the next thing we're
done great
okay thanks and for those on the
livestream actually I think we're going
to stream the very next meeting we're
having as well but we have to hang out
from here okay this is really becoming
reality TV okay all right see you later
all right